Professor Charles
Bailyn: We had gotten,
at the end of last time,
to the Big Rip.
This is where the
ever-expanding Cosmological
Constant--which is,
of course, a contradiction in
terms.
If you imagine that dark energy
is not a Cosmological Constant,
that it's actually increasing
in time, rips everything to
shreds.
The Universe becomes infinite
in size in a finite amount of
time and everything gets pulled
apart.
What I want to start by doing
today is to go back and do that
again slowly,
okay?
Because I think this is not a
simple line of reasoning that
leads you to this.
So, let's go all the way back
to what we know about the
Universe from observing
galaxies, supernovas,
things like that.
We know that the Universe is
expanding and that,
we know.
Hubble already figured that out.
We know this from the Hubble
Law, and from other--just,
in general, from the study of
standard candles at relatively
low redshift.
So, distances out to,
I don't know,
Z of less than 0.2,
or so.
You can't tell the difference
between an accelerating or a
decelerating Universe.
All you know is that it's
expanding, and you can figure
out how fast it's expanding.
Now, the next question then
becomes the rate of expansion.
Is the rate of expansion
changing?
Is it accelerating?
Is it decelerating?
What's going on there?
And so, you want to compare
acceleration versus
deceleration,
which is a fancy word,
as you know,
for slowing down.
And deceleration:
this is relatively easy to
grasp.
This is what happens because of
matter.
Matter exists.
It's got gravitational force,
and gravitational force tends
to hold things together.
So, if you've got something
that's moving apart,
and there's some gravitational
force, it'll tend to hold it
together, and thus,
slow it down.
Most of the matter,
it turns out,
is this weird dark matter,
which we don't understand,
but that's what's responsible
for the deceleration.
If you're going to make it go
faster, you need something much
weirder that pushes outward,
that has repulsive force.
This, we believe,
actually exists.
This, we label dark energy.
And so, the question of,
"is it accelerating or is it
decelerating," is basically a
question of how much dark energy
is there versus how much matter
is there,
because the more--if you have
more of this than this,
then it will accelerate and
vice versa.
And what we have discovered by
supernovae observations with
redshifts of greater than 0.3,
and by now, out to about a
redshift of 1,
or so, demonstrate that--well,
what exactly does this say?
Let's go slowly.
In the past,
the Universe was expanding more
slowly than it is now,
and therefore--those three dots
are the mathematical symbol for
therefore.
Therefore, the Universe is
accelerating,
and therefore,
there's more dark energy than
there is matter.
And you'll recall,
we did the little pie chart of
the Universe,
and it turns out,
it's 3/4 dark energy and 1/4
matter.
And those proportions are
determined by the rate at which
the Universe is accelerating.
Not the rate at which it's
expanding, but the rate at which
it's accelerating,
because that's the change in
the expansion.
Fine, so far--or maybe it isn't
fine.
I should pose that as a
question.
Fine?
This is the basic premise of
where we had gotten to about a
week ago.
Yes sir?
Student: How does dark
energy cause acceleration?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Huh?
Student: How dark energy
[inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: How dark energy
causes acceleration?
Excellent question.
I have no idea,
because we don't have any idea
what it is.
And it shows up-- the reason we
have even a name for it,
you know, is that it showed up
in Einstein's equations as a
potential contribution to the
Universe that you could add,
but didn't have to.
A constant of integration,
for those of you who like that
kind of thing.
What it is, physically?
Very hard to understand.
The only physical explanation
that's been offered--well,
many have been offered.
But the only one that connects
to anything else we know is the
idea that it's the vacuum energy
predicted by quantum mechanics.
And it turns out that if that's
true, it ought to be 10^(120)
times stronger.
And so, that's not a good
prediction.
And so, exactly how this
works--what the mechanism is,
what the nature of this stuff
is?
Completely unknown.
And the only reason we think
it's there is that we see its
effect.
We see the Universe getting
faster.
And so, it's just a name that's
attached to whatever is causing
that effect.
Okay. Yes?
Student: How do you know
the Universe is expanding more
slowly?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Was expanding more
slowly than it is now,
right.
So, that is this transformation
between these two different
kinds of graphs,
one of which is the observed
graph and one of which is the
plot of the scale factor versus
time.
Here's now.
Here's 1.
We're at 1 and now.
And so, if it were not
accelerating,
if it were just coasting along,
that would be a straight line.
And what happens is,
we can look back into the past
and what we see is this.
So, at this point,
if you think about it--believe
me, for a sec,
that this is true.
Supposing you were sitting here.
The rate of expansion is the
slope of this line.
That's how much you're
expanding.
And so, at this point,
the slope is shallower than it
is up here.
And so, one interpretation of
this line is that in the past,
it used to be expanding,
you know, like this,
and now, it's expanding like
this.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Ah,
how do you know it's doing that
particular shape?
Well, you, of course,
observe points all along the
way, here.
Now, we're about to get to the
question of whether that shape
actually continues.
If you asked,
how do you know that it would
continue this way,
that, of course,
you don't know for sure.
If you invent some piece of
magic whereby everything changes
right now for some obscure
reason, it could go off in some
other direction.
But the assumption is that
whatever it is that's--that we
do not live at a special time,
and that, therefore,
whatever it is that's doing the
accelerating is going to keep at
it.
And indeed, the whole of the
Big Rip, which is where I'm
going with this,
comes about by asking the
question,
supposing the acceleration rate
is changing in a different way
from the way we thought it was
going to.
Just to complete the thought
here, the way this works out in
the observational plane,
you'll recall,
looks like this.
Here's the empty Universe in
this set of units.
And you observe a bunch of
supernovae and they seem to be
doing that.
And that line,
if you, then,
transform redshift and
distance--this is kind of a
weird measure of distance--into
scale factor and time.
Let me make this line solid,
so that the two graphs
correspond.
This line and that line
correspond with each other.
And so, as you observe many
points along here,
that's essentially observing
many points along here.
Okay, yes?
Student: Given the
empirical data that we know now,
if we were to extra--to improve
to extrapolate that curve,
would it actually intersect
with the t-axis or would
we need to have [Inaudible]?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Ah,
let me come back to that.
Let me come back to that.
The answer is,
yes, it does go to zero.
It doesn't keep going up like
this, but let me come back to
that in a second,
and you'll see why.
Okay.
So, it's all a balance of dark
energy versus dark matter,
or matter, in general,
but the dark matter
predominates.
And, at the moment,
it is true that the dark energy
is--there's more of it.
It exerts more,
more of an influence on the
Universe;
therefore, the Universe is not
just expanding,
but also accelerating.
We know that because these
points are above the line,
not below the line.
But this didn't always have to
be true.
This balance changes with time.
So, currently,
DE blows away the DM,
but this can change.
This changes.
In fact, this is almost certain
to change with time.
And the reason is that the
energy density of the dark
energy and the matter density of
the dark matter behave
differently as you change the
size of the Universe.
It's all about the density
here, so, matter density in the
past.
You have the same amount of
matter, but the Universe was
smaller.
Density is equal to mass over
volume.
So, if you have the same
M, but smaller V,
this would have to have been
bigger in the past.
And, in fact,
it goes as the scale factor
cubed, or 1 over the scale
factor cubed.
Just because volume goes as a
linear scale cubed.
So, in the past,
there was--the matter density
was much greater than it is
right now,
and therefore,
the gravitational force trying
to hold the Universe together
was greater than it is right
now.
But the Cosmological Constant
is constant, and what that means
is that its density is constant.
And what that means is that,
in the past,
the dark energy density was the
same as it is now.
That's just the way this
particular piece of Einstein's
equations works.
It's a constant.
Now, if you're about to ask the
question, well,
how does anything behave that
way, I'm going to give you the
same answer.
You know, they have this
wonderful thing in the British
Parliament where they ask the
Prime Minister
questions--obnoxious questions.
And when they start getting too
many obnoxious questions in a
row, what he'll do is,
he'll look at the camera and
say, "I refer the Honorable
Gentleman to the answer I gave
some moments ago."
So, if you're going to ask what
this is and why it behaves that
way, I will refer you to the
answer I gave to the Honorable
Gentleman some moments ago;
namely, I don't have a clue.
Something they don't generally
say in political situations.
All right.
So, it's the same as now.
But look at the implication of
this.
If the matter density gets
bigger and bigger and bigger as
you go into the past,
and the dark energy density
does not, then at some point in
the past, it must have been true
that the matter density
overwhelms the dark energy.
And then, at some point in the
past, the dark energy and the
dark matter exert comparable
effects on the Universe.
And before that,
dark matter wins--that is to
say, the Universe was
decelerating.
Now turn this around and go in
chronological order.
From the start of the Universe
until some moment,
the Universe decelerated.
It was expanding,
but it kept getting slower.
Then, after some moment--and we
know that this moment was in our
past, because after this moment,
it starts to accelerate.
And we know that it's
accelerating now.
And so, at some point in the
past, there was a magic moment
where everything balanced,
and then, it started to
accelerate.
So, now, what does this look
like on our graphs?
What does this look like on the
graphs, here?
Well, let's do the a
versus t thing,
again.
Here we are.
Here's our reference empty
Universe.
And so, recently,
it's been accelerating.
So, you know,
if we look into the past.
And then, the prediction is,
the extrapolation back to zero
looks kind of like this.
And remember,
if it looks like this,
it's decelerating.
If it looks like this,
it's accelerating.
And so, the dotted lines are
extrapolations based on the idea
that the dark energy is the
Cosmological Constant,
and the dark matter behaves
like matter ought to behave.
And so, if you make those two
assumptions, this is the curve
you get.
And so, this is what you expect
for Ω_matter = .25;
Ω_λ = .75 at
present.
And so, you can predict,
given these two quantities,
and a measurement of
H_0 equals
about 70.
This gives you an age of the
Universe.
That is to say,
the time from when a = 0
to now--of the Universe,
of something like 13 point;
I think it's actually,
at the moment,
13.4 billion years,
plus or minus,
I don't know .4,
or something like that.
Under the assumption that λ
equals--that the Cosmological
Constant really is constant,
that you've got these kinds of
proportions, and this kind of
current Hubble Constant.
And then, you can just
extrapolate all these lines in
whatever direction you like,
and figure out where it crosses
a = 0.
Yes?
Student: Can we see back
to [Inaudible]
see it as deceleration or is it
[Inaudible]?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Excellent question.
The question is,
"Can we see far back in the
past to see this deceleration?"
The answer is,
just about yes,
and I'll show you some data in
a second.
Because this is a very strong
prediction of the model--that is
to say that it should turn
around.
If you're imagining that
there's something wacky about
supernovae, and that,
as you go into the past,
they look fainter or something,
as you were assuming on the
problem set,
then you wouldn't necessarily
predict that that would turn
around and do the other thing as
you go further back in the past.
So, this is a very strong
prediction of what ought to
happen cosmologically,
and so, of course,
people have been trying to test
it.
Yes?
Student: If the density
of the Universe is changing,
then wouldn't it indicate that
we're in some special time right
now,
given the fact that the current
density of the Universe is
really close to the critical
density?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah.
So, the question is about,
if the density is changing,
why does the--what's so unusual
about now, that we're close to
the critical density?
The thing you have to remember
is, the critical density also
changes with time.
It's based on--remember the
critical density.
It's 3H^(2) over
something or other.
Well, H changes with
time, because the velocity is
more or less the same,
but the distances all change.
Student: So,
it's always been pretty close
to the critical density?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
what is true is that--the way
it works out,
mathematically,
what's true is that the sum of
these two quantities has always
been close to 1.
The ratio changes,
but the sum of these two--if
the total Ω starts as 1,
it stays at 1.
But, it turns out,
it's the total Ω that you
can--that is conserved.
And we'll come back to that
point a little later.
Okay, let's see.
Right. Okay. So, yes.
Let's go there.
Let's go for the observational
evidence.
What would you expect it to be?
Here we go.
This one, again.
We keep going back and forth
between these two plots.
That's what it's all about.
So, here's empty Universe,
as always.
And then, in this plot,
acceleration means a positive
slope.
So, if you're moving up in this
plot, the Universe has been
accelerating--is accelerating at
that particular redshift,
at that particular time in the
past.
So, you know,
the data we've looked at so far
kind of look like points along a
line like this.
That's the demonstration that
the Universe is now
accelerating.
So, here's the prediction.
And, you know,
here's a magic moment where,
at that point,
this slope is flat,
and so, on this side,
it's decelerating,
and on this side,
it's accelerating.
And the question is,
is it getting further away
from--is it moving up compared
to the empty Universe,
or is it moving down compared
to the empty Universe?
Because the empty Universe
neither accelerates nor
decelerates.
That's the definition of an
empty Universe.
It doesn't have any mass.
It doesn't have any energy.
The expansion rate is constant
forever.
So, if you're going this way
with respect to that line,
or going this way with respect
to that line,
you're accelerating,
and if you're coming back,
going in the other direction,
you're decelerating.
So, here's a closed Universe,
right?
This is a Big Crunch Universe,
which is going to re-collapse,
because it's decelerating all
the time.
Now, interestingly,
this turnaround point,
where you turn around between
accelerating and decelerating,
is not so far back into the
past.
If you believe this set of
parameters, the standard model,
it's at around 0.8.
We can see stuff at 0.8.
And you could hope to go and
see things even further out.
Turns out, it's kind of--now,
right at--if you only go out to
about 0.8, which is about as far
out as they did for the first
time round,
you're not going to see the
turnaround, because,
you know, it's just more or
less flat.
You've got a few points out
there, and you're going to have
a tough time telling the
difference between that and that
at this point here.
But if you go out just a little
bit further, you might really be
able to see this turnaround
happening.
Unfortunately,
that turns out to be hard,
observationally.
It's hard to see supernovae
with redshifts greater than 1,
for a number of different
reasons.
First of all, they're faint.
The further away they are,
the fainter they are.
Second of all,
they appear on top of galaxies.
Obviously, they live in
galaxies.
The further away you look,
the galaxies look smaller,
and so, the supernova appear to
be--the further away you look,
the more light from the galaxy
the supernova is superimposed
on.
And it becomes harder to
separate the light from the
supernova and the light from the
galaxy that it lives in.
And the third part is that the
light is redshifted.
Very redshifted.
Redshifted by a factor of two.
So, supernovae give off most of
their light in optical light,
which we can observe.
But by the time they're at a
redshift of 1,
all the wavelengths are
doubled.
And so, most of the radiation
is in the infrared,
which is much harder to see
from the ground,
because everything glows in the
infrared.
And, as I said before,
it's like looking in the
daytime.
The whole sky is glowing.
Your telescope is glowing.
It's just really hard to make
those kinds of observations.
It is possible,
however, to do--it's much
easier to do this from space.
Now, faint is faint.
It doesn't matter whether
you're in orbit or not.
But the other two things are
greatly aided by looking from
space.
Point two.
You get much better images from
space.
And you may recall,
last time, I showed you a
picture of a supernova,
and from the ground,
you know, it was a little extra
light on top of some galaxy.
And then, when you looked from
space, the galaxy was clearly
delineated.
And then, the supernova was a
tiny point in the outskirts of
that galaxy.
So, it makes it much,
much easier to separate the
galaxy from the supernova.
And it is also true that the
infrared background light is
much fainter,
because you can keep stuff cold
out there.
The infrared background light
is much fainter and there's no
atmospheric absorption.
The atmosphere actually absorbs
a large fraction of the infrared
light that hits us.
That's actually why the
greenhouse effect works,
because light comes in as
optical light and it makes it
all the way through.
Then, it heats up the surface
of the Earth.
The Earth radiates heat,
which doesn't make it through
the atmosphere and it gets
trapped.
So, there's no atmospheric
absorption out there,
and so, you have a much easier
time doing this from space.
So, what they have been doing
is, recently,
people, and in particular,
a guy named Adam Riess,
have been using the space
telescope, the Hubble Space
Telescope, to find high redshift
supernovae.
There is a flaw in the way the
space telescope is designed from
the point of view of trying to
do this experiment.
And the flaw is that it doesn't
look at very much of the sky at
once.
It only looks at a small field
of view.
So, you don't find many,
because you're just not looking
at that big a part of the sky.
And so, you only look at a tiny
piece of the sky at once.
However, they have
spent--because this is of some
clear importance,
they have spent many,
many, many hundreds of
observing hours with the space
telescope trying to track down a
few supernovae at a redshift
greater than 1.
And they have now succeeded in
doing so.
So, here's what the data look
like.
This is from Adam's recent
paper, 2004.
I guess it's no longer quite so
recent.
And this is the plot.
Let me see if I can focus this.
It's actually the Xerox quality.
We have a joke in astronomy
that many important objects turn
out to be LSXTS,
which stands for Low
Significant Xerox Transient
Source.
That means you've made a Xerox
and a little blip appears on
your graph and somebody says,
what's that point in the upper
right-hand corner?
And you say,
oh, that's the Xerox machine.
All right.
So, I apologize for that.
But look what's happening.
This is redshift.
This is the plot we've been
looking at before,
0, .5,1.0,1.5,
and 2.
And this is the Delta (m
– M) axis.
So, 0 is what you expect the
empty Universe to have.
And he has marked on here a
different set of lines from the
set of lines I've been drawing.
But, nevertheless,
you can see what's going on.
Here are--these are all
supernovae--all the supernovae
they know.
These kinds of fuzzy gray
points are the ones they found
with the space telescope.
The ones in here are the
ground-based ones known at the
time.
And what they've done is
they've averaged them together
in groups of redshift,
grouping by redshift.
That's the bottom thing.
So, each one of these points is
an average of many supernovae.
This point is an average of
these two.
And then, as you get down to
lower redshifts where they have
lots and lots of them,
the precision gets much better.
But you can definitely see
what's happening.
Here, out to about,
you know, .5,
.8, it's going up.
And then, it does definitely
seem like it's going down.
And so, there really is,
now, some evidence for this
turnaround.
Now, it kind of all depends on
these two points.
I have a rule of thumb.
My rule of thumb is you can put
your thumb over any one point,
because you never know what
screw up might have happened in
any one measurement.
So, I can't really do that on
the top.
But if I do this,
and I make that point go away,
you could still kind of draw a
line that keeps going up.
It would miss this point by a
little, but not by a lot.
It's really this that does it.
It's these last two individual
supernovae down there,
which really make the case that
the thing is turning over and
coming back down.
Now, you have to worry a little
bit--and there's actually a good
reason to worry about the
brightness of high redshift
supernovae.
And let me give you one
particular reason to worry,
namely, gravitational lensing.
Remember gravitational lensing?
You stick some mass in the
middle, between you and the
object you're looking at.
It focuses the light.
Gravitational lensing makes
things look brighter.
The further away you look at
something, the more likely it is
that there's something in
between that will do the
lensing.
So, first of all,
point one: more distant
objects, more likely to be
lensed.
Point two: if you're out
looking for very distant,
very faint objects,
which are the ones you're going
to see first?
Student: The bright ones.
Professor Charles
Bailyn: The bright ones,
yes.
At the, sort of,
faint limit,
you see abnormally bright
things first.
I can't even spell
that--abnormally bright things,
preferentially.
So, you could imagine,
if you're basing your entire
cosmology on one or two high
redshift supernovae,
you got to ask yourself the
question: supposing those happen
to be lensed?
So, let me now go back to this
plot.
Here's the plot.
So, if they're lensed,
then they're brighter--then
they seem to be brighter than
they actually are.
They're actually fainter than
they look.
That would have the effect that
this one actually ought to be up
here, and this one actually
ought to be up here,
if they were lensed by some
amount.
So, if these things are lenses,
then the true,
correct position of these
points would be higher up in the
graph than it actually is.
So, this is the effect of
lensing.
Now, when it was only one of
these points,
people were very concerned
about this.
Now that there's two,
people are a lot less
concerned, because,
you know, it would be pretty
bad luck to have both of the
supernovae that you know about
at high redshift turn out to be
lensed.
If they had twenty,
this whole problem would go
away, because there would be no
possible way that you could be
so unlucky--well,
you could calculate the
probability that you would be so
unlucky as to have the first
twenty high redshift supernovae
you know happen to line up right
behind some massive object,
and it would be some incredibly
small probability.
So, each time you observe
another one of these things out
there and it's low,
you get around this lensing
problem.
I should say this is only one
of a number of problems.
These things are very hard to
observe.
They're very faint objects.
But, nevertheless,
I think, at the moment,
the evidence for this
turnaround is highly suggestive,
but not yet wholly conclusive.
All right.
But now, suppose you actually
want to get higher accuracy than
just seeing the thing
turnaround.
Because, suppose dark energy
isn't constant.
Suppose the Big Rip really is
going to happen.
Then, DE density increases with
time.
This leads to the Big Rip,
as we discussed last time.
And therefore,
the dark energy density was
less in the past than in now.
And therefore,
the deceleration,
the moment of balance between
deceleration and acceleration
was more recent.
Because, as you go back in the
past under this new scenario
where the density of dark energy
is increasing with time,
it's therefore decreasing as
you go into the past.
So, as you go into the past,
two things happen – the
density of matter gets bigger,
and the density of dark energy
gets less.
So, there's an additional
effect that will make that
crossover happen earlier.
And so, to summarize on these,
by now, almost boring and
ubiquitous plots,
here.
All right.
So, here's the,
kind of, standard cosmological
model, and if it's going to be
a--oh,
and then, this predicts in the
future that it's going to go
something like,
if it's a Big Rip,
then what happens is,
it's doing this,
and it's going to do that.
Because the dark matter takes
over from the dark energy more
recently in the past.
Because you've also lost oomph
in your dark energy,
but the dark energy's getting
bigger and bigger with time.
This, then, translates onto
this plot.
And here is what we expect,
and here's the kind of
prediction into the future.
Future of observations.
Further into the past in time.
And what you would expect is
that this would sort of keel
over earlier.
So, this is a Big Rip cosmology.
Big Rip cosmology has the
same--Big Rip would have the
same expansion rate now,
the same acceleration now,
but more acceleration in the
future than you'd expect,
and more deceleration in the
past.
And so, it's important,
not just to see this
turnaround, but to actually
plot, in detail,
where that line goes.
Because, if it turns out that
your supernovae are kind of
lined up like this,
or they're kind of lined up
like this--you already know that
there are a bunch of them like
this--or that they're kind of
lined up like this,
makes a huge difference in how
you understand the dark energy,
and tells you something new
about the dark energy.
In fact, it tells you the first
thing you know about the dark
energy other than that it
exists--namely,
that it would be getting bigger
or less big, or maybe staying
constant as a function of time.
Yes?
Student: Well if the
deceleration was earlier than
expected following the Big Bip
cosmology,
wouldn't we have seen it
already since we [Inaudible]?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
these three lines,
at about, you know,
0.8, are very,
very close together.
They don't diverge all that
much until a redshift--until the
turnaround, at about a redshift
of .8 to 1.
Now, in principle,
you could go out and make a
whole bunch of--you know,
measure 10,000 of these things
at a redshift of .5,
and try and distinguish that
way.
Okay.
So, how are we going to figure
this out?
The space telescope,
kind of, finds these things one
at a time.
It's going to be awfully tough
to make this distinction.
But let me introduce you to two
projects currently underway,
the goal of which is to figure
this out.
They do the exact two things
that we've just been talking
about.
One is designed to go
deep-to-high redshift,
and the other is designed to do
many, many, many,
at intermediate redshift.
So, there is something called
the--so, there's a space
mission, space telescope.
This is called JDEM,
stands for Joint Dark Energy
Mission.
And the joint means joint
between NASA and the Department
of Energy.
Whoever named this stuff dark
energy gets a little prize,
because now we get money from
the Department of Energy to
study it.
Let's see.
And the idea--of which an
example is something called Snap
1 Proposal.
That's the supernova
acceleration probe.
Student: This is part of
the JDEM?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: This is an example
of one mission proposed to be
JDEM.
This is an example.
And it's an example I'm
familiar with,
because we have people here at
Yale who are working on it.
And there are competitors.
They haven't actually selected
the thing yet.
And what this is going to be
is, it's a space telescope that
differs from the current space
telescope in two major ways.
One is, it has a wide field of
view, dozens of times bigger
than the current space
telescope.
So, it can do twenty--let me
see if I can remember.
It's like twenty--it's over 100
times bigger field of view than
the current space telescope.
So, the discovery rate of
supernovae will be much,
much greater.
And it's optimized for the
infrared.
And so, its goal is to find
many supernovae with redshift
greater than 1,
perhaps out to a redshift of 2.
That's its purpose in life.
And proposals are currently
being evaluated for this.
Launch time is supposed to
be–well, the optimists say
2013, but that means
congressional funding this year,
which is actually unlikely.
More likely 2016 or 2017,
and then, we'll know.
Yes?
Student: Is optimization
for infrared or are there any
other predicted,
sort of, benefits of having
[Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
it's very nice to look at the
infrared, because anything at
high redshift shines in the
infrared.
And so, if you're looking at
high redshift galaxies,
how galaxies evolve,
and so forth,
this is useful,
too.
There's actually a big debate
over whether you totally set the
thing up to do nothing but
supernovae,
or whether you sort of
generalize it and spend half
your time doing other things.
And there's one other project,
at least, which I'll describe
next week, that these guys are
interested in doing,
but there's a real tradeoff
between making it a general
purpose telescope like the
Hubble,
or doing this one thing
especially well.
And that's, you know,
the kind of thing that's
currently under discussion.
So, SNAP is one example of
where people might go in the
future.
Another is a ground-based
project called the Large
Synoptic Survey Telescope.
This is otherwise known as LSST.
LSST.
The plan is this.
And this has a lot of other
science besides this.
It's going to do a full survey
of the sky every three days.
So, it's going to--every three
nights, it marches across the
entire sky, takes a really deep
image of the sky.
And so, the consequence of this
for cosmology is that you find
every low and intermediate
redshift supernova.
That's tens to hundreds of
thousands--tens of--maybe 10,000
a year, approximately.
So, you find lots of these
things.
So, first of all,
you build up incredible
statistics out to a redshift of
about 1/2.
So, huge statistics to Z
of about 1/2.
That's kind of where its limit
is going to kick in.
And you also can study the
details of sub-classes of
supernovae.
So, this is important,
because you know if you're
fooling yourself,
because the distant supernovae
are different,
somehow, from the local
supernovae.
They're fainter for some reason.
But in the local sample,
only one in 100 is of the faint
kind.
If you've got 10,000,
that means you've got,
you know, a sample of 100 of
the weird subclass that's
causing you trouble.
So, this will be hugely
helpful, not only in beating
down the statistics so that you
can tell the difference between
lines that are really quite
close to each other,
theoretical predictions that
are close to each other,
but it also will test the
systematic problems that you
might have different kinds of
supernovae and generally enhance
your overall confidence that you
know what you're talking about.
Also, these kinds of sky
surveys are of benefit for many,
many other fields of astronomy.
The issue with this is the
following statistic.
Thirty terabytes of data per
night, right?
That's 30,000 gig per night.
Thirty million megabytes every
night.
And so, this is not something
that us normal astronomers can
handle, and so,
the recent news from the LSST
project is, Google has joined
the project.
And so, we're bringing in
the--yeah, right.
We're bringing in the big boys
for this.
And I think this is kind of
Google Universe,
right?
Because it's a--you know,
you take all--you do this for a
few years, and you've done 100
sky surveys.
You can then add them all up
and get incredibly deep data.
And so, I guess Google figured,
you know, if somebody's going
to be piling up a catalog of the
entire known Universe,
they'd better be a part of it.
And it's fortunate for us,
because they're probably the
only people in the world who can
create a database of data coming
in at this rate.
And, I should say,
keep in mind that you have to
actually, not just acquire this
data, you have to actually look
at it each night.
Because you've got to actually
discover these supernovae in
real time, because they're going
to be gone three weeks from now,
or three months now.
And so, you not only have to
pile up 30 terabytes of data
every night, you've got to
actually look at it and find all
the interesting objects.
So - Student:
[Inaudible]
can they do it for?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: The plan,
currently, is to operate for at
least five and probably ten
years.
They have a site picked out.
They're going to put it down in
Chile, actually,
on the mountain where our tiny
telescope is.
And so, we actually like this,
because they'll pay for some of
the infrastructure costs down
there--hopefully,
for all of the infrastructure
costs.
But negotiation's still in
progress.
And they have a whole design
planned for this.
It's all ready to go,
but it's going to cost a fair
amount of money to build.
And what's even more important:
it's going to cost an enormous
amount of money to run,
just on a night-to-night basis.
So, actually,
the construction costs of the
telescope are not the dominant
cost.
The dominant costs are building
the software and running the
program.
And it turns out,
that's harder to get some rich
guy to give you a $100,000,000
for.
And it's ground-based,
so it doesn't fall into the
NASA category.
And so, it isn't clear where
the money is going to come from.
They actually have a fair
amount of private money already
piled up.
And, as I say,
they have detailed,
elaborate plans for this thing.
You can look at their website.
In fact, you will have to look
at their website,
because that's going to be part
of the problem set.
And so, these are two of the
projects, which are currently
being designed and hopefully
soon will be built,
that are going to try and push
this a little further and try
and find out more about the dark
energy than simply the fact that
it exists.
Okay, let me put back up this
piece of paper with details.
Remember, no sections on Monday.
No sections on Monday.